what mankind has achieved so far can
hardly be overestimated it's possible
that man will be able to send the first
interstellar probes to the Alpha
Centauri star system launched a mission
to Mars and fully explore our nearest
satellites as soon as in the next decade
or two and that in spite of the fact
that even a century has not yet passed
since the first human ventured into the
space so what will humanity be able to
achieve in hundreds thousands or even
millions of years to come
life established itself on the planet
Earth by pure chance however the space
is so great that the same chance event
could occur in millions of other cases
if this is so why is the universe silent
we live on a planet that is considered
young in comparison to other planetary
objects humanity is just 2.8 million
years old while the earth is 4.5 billion
years old long before our planet
appeared thousands of such habitable
worlds were already in existence and
these objects are still somewhere in the
nearest galaxies imagine if mankind had
appeared a billion years earlier what
technologies would we have had at our
disposal today based on calculations by
a number of today's astrophysicists it
is an undeniable fact that there exists
a great number of similar planets in the
space the presence of an advanced
extraterrestrial life on such planets is
simply a natural consequence why is it
then that we still haven't received a
single sign that would indicate the
presence of anyone else around us in the
space what could be the reasons for this
absolute silence of the universe to try
to answer this question I will tell you
about one of the most atypical and
fascinating puzzles of modern cosmology
the Fermi paradox Enrico Fermi
is a scientist of Italian descent who
emigrated to the United States shortly
before the outbreak of World War two
Fermi worked on the design of the first
nuclear reactor but he became well known
for a phrase they happened to drop in
the cafeteria of the Los Alamos
laboratory during an informal
conversation in 1950 Fermi together with
three other colleagues we're discussing
a cartoon published in The New Yorker
magazine there was a picture of aliens
unloading trash cans from flying saucers
landed on their planet the cartoon was
associated with real disappearance of
trash cans in New York and aliens got
into the picture because of the growing
interest in extraterrestrial
civilizations in those years when
discussing this cartoon the scientists
grew to be more serious and then firmly
uttered a phrase that was to lie in the
basis of an entire paradox have you ever
wondered where they are according to the
scientists idea if extraterrestrial
civilizations could really exist we
would have had at least three types of
evidence the presence of alien probes
ships or radio emissions however despite
all the ongoing research none of these
has been discovered so far but Fermi was
by far now the only scientists who
thought about this this question was
raised much earlier by the Russian
philosopher and inventor Konstantin
Tsiolkovsky and in 1975 astrophysicist
Michael Hart described in detailed the
reasons of this paradox Fermi's question
was a sensible one to ask
just imagine any one of us can look at
the night sky right now and see
thousands of small stars according to
scientists there are about 100 billion
of them in the Milky Way alone 20% of
which have their own planetary system
furthermore in each of these systems
there should be at least one planet
similar to the earth and 10% of these
planets that can potentially support
life may well have an intelligent
civilization
how is it possible that with such a high
probability of the existence of
extraterrestrial life to solve this
riddle the American astronomer Frank
Drake developed a simple mathematical
formula in 1961 it calculated the
probability of existence of intelligent
races in the universe here is this
formula M this is the number of
civilizations which use communication
methods that we could detect eyes the
average annual rate of emergence of
stellar systems in our galaxy f sub-p
stars that have planets and sub a is the
number of planets of satellites that can
potentially support life F sub L is the
number of inhabited planets that develop
life F sub I is the probability of the
emergence of intelligent life on
inhabited planets F sub C is the
fraction of civilizations with
detectable forms of communication L is
the time length of a detectable signal
many astrophysicists have tried to
calculate each of the presented values
but to this day the Drake Equation has
no final solution given the absence of
any signals from nearby stellar systems
it can be assumed that any civilization
that grows to be technologically
advanced runs a great risk of inevitable
self-destruction for example due to a
nuclear war or ecological collapse thus
any developed race has very little time
to be noticed however if this does not
happen any civilization will sooner or
later reach a level of advancement that
is thousands of times higher than ours
in 1964 Soviet astrophysicist Nikolai
Kardashev developed and published the
method of technological advancement of
civilization called the Kardashev scale
using this method the scientists
suggested an idea about the capabilities
of such developed races but these
capabilities would depend on the amount
of useful energy they could make you
solve
according to Kardashev the first type
includes civilizations that are able to
use all the energy available on their
planet more developed races can use all
the energy emitted by the main star and
the third type of race is able to use
the energy of the according to
astronomer Carl Sagan so far our level
is 70% that of civilizations of the
first type and we will be able to reach
tower level completely in one or two
centuries but even earlier organisms
that appeared in the universe
comparatively recently could well have
reached the level of advancement of the
third type of civilization with this
kind of technologies any races will be
able to move through the space at a
speed close to the speed of light or
even faster if this really happened we
would hardly miss signs of their
presence
however the universe has never given us
a single sign of this it is likely that
the reason for this is that we use only
radio observation methods to search for
other civilizations in the galaxy in the
entire history of the research on
extraterrestrial civilizations not a
single star has been discovered that
would demonstrate unusually intense
radio waves this leads us to the
conclusion that we're the only
civilization in our part of the galaxy
that uses radio waves for communication
perhaps if other civilizations do exist
we don't notice them because they use
completely different types of
communication the universe is full of
things we're unaware of and if someone
does live thousands of light-years away
from us they might be able to use
channels of communication unknown to us
for example neutrinos unfortunately this
version of the solution of the Fermi
paradox is not the only one many
scientists believe that our solitariness
and the space is an inevitable fact
maybe you would simply don't know why
other civilizations have died out others
suggest that would simply have not yet
reached the
level of development sufficient for
communicating with the universe sir ood
keeps silent others proponents of the
so-called zoo theory believe that our
level of development is too low compared
to extraterrestrial races our radio
signals disappear into the distant
depths of the outer space without a
trace and who knows maybe those who see
them simply don't understand what they
mean or maybe intelligent aliens are
aware of our attempts but will respond
only in the fullness of time